laker ball  bucks leaded by three here's lebron for  three  bucks by six just getting underway  second quarter here's lebron 4-3  once again it's lebron james  here's lebron for three what a night  for lebron played by lopez and harrell  with the side jump  rebounded by kuzma good hustle pops it  outside  here's lebron with a deep three again  and hits  his right shoulder with rhythm and right  here he's feeling it five for eight from  three-point line  three on the shot clock james with the  long three and  knocks it down lebron james  with his sixth three-pointer you may say  this is lucky  or late no this is what you want as a  guard  you want somebody taller and slower on  you so you can shoot  without a hand in your face yeah his  hand is up but it's not in his face  so you can shoot without a hand in your  face his hand is up but it's not in his  face